I talked to so many smart fantastic
ambitious idealistic hard-working kids
and there right out of college there in
their entry-level jobs and I'll ask them
how is it going and they'll say I think
I'm gonna quit and I'm like why they say
to me I'm not making an impact I'm like
you know you've been here eight months
right they treat the sense of
fulfillment or even love like it's a
scavenger hunt like it's something you
look for my millennial friends they've
gone through so many jobs they're either
getting fired I mean it was mutual or
they're quitting because they're not
making an impact or they're not finding
anything they're looking for they're not
feeling fulfilled as if it's a scavenger
hunt love a job you find joy from is not
something you discover it's not like I
found love here it is I found a job I
love that's not how it works both of
those things require hard work you are
in love because you work very hard every
single day of your life to stay in love
you find a job that brings you ultimate
joy because you work hard every single
day to serve those around you and you
maintain that joy it's not a discovery
but the problem is this sense of
impatience it's as if an entire
generation is standing at the foot of a
mountain they know exactly what they
want they can see the summit what they
can't see is the mountain this large a
movable object that doesn't mean you
have to do your time that's not what I'm
talking about take a helicopter climb I
don't care but there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
our journeys the problem is this entire
generation has an institutionalized
sense of impatience and do they have the
patience to go on the journey to
maintain love to feel fulfilled or do
they just quit and on to the next dump
and on to the next ghost and on to the
next by the way ghosting means the lack
of skill to have a confrontation
you date somebody for six months eight
months and then just stop replying just
delete them from everything
now for the person who is doing the
ghosting oh that's certainly easier than
a confrontation with the person on the
receiving end of the ghost thing it's
like there's a death there's suddenly
shun there's panic they call out their
warning they call out their word they
think it's you they think it's them do
you have any idea the destruction that
we reap on people by ghosting them and
then because there's the lack of social
skills to call out and ask for help they
internalize and it makes them feel awful
to the point at the worst they will kill
themselves slightly one level down
they'll get depressed but the lowest
level that we can hope for is they will
go through life and I'm not talking
about ghosting I'm talking an entire
generation that if we don't fix this
we'll go through life where everything's
just fine my friendships are fine my
work is fine you know same old same old
nothing's ever amazing and the scavenger
hunt continues we're taking a generation
that is lower self-esteem we're taking a
generation that has a lack of cocka
cocka mechanisms to deal with stress
we're capable dealing with a generation
that wants all those things fixed
immediately
and we're placing them in work
environments that values money more than
people do know that most of the business
philosophies most of the business
theories that we embrace and see a
standard today are not standard they're
theories left over from the 80s and 90s
the concept of shareholder supremacy was
a theory proposed in the late 1970s it
was popularized in the 80s and eighties
the concept of using mass layoffs to
balance the books did not exist in the
United States prior to the 1980s it did
not exist it became popular in the 80s
and 90s the 80s and 90s were boom years
anyone could make money relative peace a
kinder gentler cold war and so all of
the business theories that were put
forth were very very selfish and all
about enriching ourselves and they
worked for those times but these times
are different these are not peaceful
times these are not boom years this is
there's globalization than the internet
what
now made everything vastly more
complicated and those theories do not
work anymore
worse they're having side effects it's
really bad because what we do is we
destroy corporate cultures the idea of
using mass layoffs can you imagine
sending someone home and saying I'm
sorry I can no longer provide for our
family because the company missed its
arbitrary projections this year that's
what we're doing that's like a coach
prioritizing the needs of the fans over
the needs of the players hoping to build
a great team it doesn't work we
dismantled things like the
glass-steagall Act glass-steagall was
passed after the Great Depression to
prevent another Great Depression from
happening it was dismantled in the 80s
and the 90s in the name of profit okay
do you know how many stock market
crashes we had between the Great
Depression and the dismantling of
glass-steagall the answer is zero and
since they dismantled glass-steagall we
had 87 the dot-com crash 2008 we've had
three stock market crashes because we've
moved
the safety mechanisms that prevent stock
market crashes from happening all in the
name of individual advancement and
profit and these are the corporate
cultures we've built corporate cultures
that value numbers over people and they
are not standard business practices they
are new and they are broken and they are
dangerous and we're asking a young
wonderful ambitious amazing generation
that needs us to work in these
environments whether we like it or not
we have to take responsibility for that
bad hand that you've been dealt it is up
to the companies to create an
environment in which you can build your
self-confidence it is up to the
companies to create an environment in
which you can learn coping mechanisms
and learn how to build strong close
relationships with people with whom you
work that you will eventually love and
sacrifice to see that they gain
environments that we will learn the
patience and the hard work that it takes
to find fulfilment in our lives to find
a sense of purpose a sense of joy yes
it's all fine and good that my
generation and older generations say to
you things like well you're the Future
Leaders we're the leaders now we're the
ones in control over the corporate
environments now and we're making your
lives worse I don't want you to jump
from job to job to job to job you will
never find what you're looking for it's
not a scavenger hunt I don't want you to
go from relationship to relationship to
relationship what I want you to do is
stand up and demand that the places in
which you work lead you properly nobody
wants to wake up in the morning and be
managed we want to wake up in the
morning and be led and we have a total
leadership crisis in America politics is
just the mirror reflection we get the
politicians we deserve we're the divided
ones we're the selfish ones we're the
broken ones
we're the ones who would sooner
sacrifice somebody else so that we may
gain it's us and until we're willing to
do the hard work of repairing the world
around us our country our politics our
businesses will not fix if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you up or that would
be like a little beacon hey believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details